rellena la tabla con números enteros
para escribir 10.2 de dos formas
diferentes
tenemos dos columnas la de las decenas y
la de los décimos tenemos 10 punto 2 10
es una decena
y tenemos dos decimos eso estuvo muy
fácil qué pasa si ahora tengo cero
decenas convertiré esas decenas en
décimos y una unidad es igual a 10
decimos multiplicar por 10 entonces
tendré 100 decimos 100 decimos
más dos décimos originales
ok tenemos 100 decimos que equivale a
esos 10 unidades más 2 decimos que
tenemos originalmente y con eso tenemos
100 decimos más 2 decimos 102 decimos
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta vaya
de borrado solo les puse los números
para que vean cómo funciona pero nuestra
respuesta es 102 decimos es igual a 10.2
veamos es correcto vamos a hacer un par
más que son súper divertidos
ahora tenemos rellenar la tabla con los
números enteros para escribir 20.1 de
tres formas diferentes 20 unidades 10
decimos así es que esto está muy fácil
tenemos ahora dos columnas las columnas
de las decenas y de los décimos
así es que 20 será igual a dos decenas
dos por diez es igual a veinte dos
decenas cuántos decimos pues uno
literalmente aquí se ve que es un décimo
vamos a reagrupar ahora sólo tengo una
sola decena
si una unidad son diez décimos
100 décimos serán una decena 100 décimos
ok con eso tenemos una decena y le
sumaremos un décimo que tenemos
originalmente tendremos 100 décimos más
undécimo igual a 101 decimos
qué pasa si ahora no tengo decenas si
todas las decenas las he convertido en
decimos pues si una vez en a eran 100
decimos ahora tengo dos decenas 200
decimos esos 200 decimos le sumar en el
décimo original y tendré entonces 201
decimos vamos a comprobar la respuesta
y es correcta vámonos con uno más esta
es la última rellena la tabla con
números enteros para escribir 0.25 dos
décimos cinco centésimos de tres formas
distintas tenemos las columnas con los
décimos y con los centésimos
literalmente podemos ver que hay dos
décimos
y cinco centésimos eso está muy fácil
vamos a reagrupar ahora sólo tengo un
10º 11º es igual a 10 centésimos si un
décimo es igual a 10
centésimos
10 centésimos + 5 centésimos tendré 15
centésimos y el que pasa ahora si tengo
20 décimos y todo lo convierto en
centésimos pues está muy sencillo
justamente aquí lo vemos por valor
posicional tenemos 25 centésimos 25
centésimos ya que dos décimos es igual a
20 centésimos vamos a comprobar la
respuesta y es correcta nos vemos en
otro vídeo